>> That's good David. Note though, that this sentence is a little bit like,
a shark enjoyed eating the frog. This is one representation for
this sentence, and under the representation we may have two action frames.
One corresponding to the word loved, another corresponded to word watching, and
then connect them, to the slot result. I hope you can see how agents might
be able to understand simple stories. In fact, this is quite similar to
the way Watson and Siri go about to understand the stories that we talk to them.
Almost surely the human interactions with the machines of tomorrow,
will not be based on the keyboards and mouses that we have today.
We'll talk to the machines, the machines will talk back to us, and
when we talk to the machines we'll be telling the machines stories.
Stories like Anika decided to have a glass of water, or
a shark enjoyed eating the frog. And when we tell the stories,
the stories will have context. They will have ambiguities. And
we will expect the machines to do common sense reasoning. The power of this
particular lesson lies in the [UNKNOWN] of a representation, that enables
a particular kind of common sense reasoning. We'll continue this discussion,
about common sense reasoning of more complex stories, in the next lesson.